hey guys today we're checking out the
new an eel and yellow joy Khan these are
in celebration of the new arms game that
is coming out on June 15 for an
incentive which I got a chance to play
very very briefly as an intended switch
launch event but that was basically it
like two minutes now is finally coming
out so after we check these out I'm
going to play a little bit of the game
with my sister Jenna I haven't played it
other than that day so you're going to
be seeing our first time real reactions
to playing the game neon yellow
surprisingly is one of my favorite
colors so when I saw that they're coming
out with these guys you better believe I
was excited I had my nails painted this
the other day and didn't look so good
this is beautiful this is my favorite
color I am ecstatic right now you look
so cool the only thing that would rival
this is hot pink these looks so great
[Music]
let's see if they look like on the
switch that looks cool
[Music]
so let me first came out everyone was
really into having the mixed and matched
colors but this has been out I'm loving
the one color on each side joy con man
hot pink oh good it looks so great I got
update shoot okay well I'm gonna do the
software update and then I buy my sister
and then we're gonna play this game what
color is on your wish list for Nintendo
joy con colors
what'll I do just punch you yeah so this
is the basic let's start with the basics
okay Ellen R I'm ready tilt the Mook oh
yeah
oh man knock you out shut your big mouth
Elsa - okay Raj
oh I'm knock you out tonight
hey oh okay well gosh we're gonna get so
rowdy
oh wait make sure you have your ID oh
okay I don't trust your hands occur no
you must be reason playa
haha quantico p.m. to grab oh yeah but
like don't look at your scar oh wait Oh
together alright
twin tell Oh Oh where's my bad one so
the triggers oh we caught up here i'm
the one i just lectured on oh I can pick
you can pick the different arms you want
okay Sparky so I can mix and match on my
arms I don't know
No
oh man wait you beat me you bet your
little bottom line are you holding you
know I just need you must be making
supper I have a loose I'm a radio
receivers away oh god let's drop him off
I can't holy crap come on I don't tell
me rolling and my hole is brawled ah it
feels so weird
do it again no no I think usually think
I did
hi well exhausting my absolutely suck at
this
my fingers are wild call me hon sweating
me too
we need to play it again ah don't let
feel it feels so weird to hold the
controller it does when I don't get a
good grip on I don't either
Wow yeah oh I think these are my face oh
I only need to get you one
Oh
and I can't ever post it well I'm not
eating up everything I'm deleting all
how am I not oh my god you take a
picture maybe I may be like hey I
think you put your baby I'm taking
picture picture hold of spring and
controller I can't figure it out I'm
like yeah I'm willing you okay okay now
that I got I'm taking it away what are
we doing okay I'm absolutely in peril
I am so bad again I can't make all the
buttons okay well maybe you should
practice yeah I'm deleting all the
footage you'll never see it to show your
clothing in any way Wow how are you
holding this I'm not telling you my
secret
I'm to arms champion I am armed with
that do I just change fighter do that's
the problem
that's the problem I'll play the
question mark
cool help ramen dude okay guys I haven't
won a match yet I need to win one
I need to focus how are you holding that
I don't know in Japan and just feel so I
keep taking pictures maybe I want it
like this how are you doing so good I'm
honestly just following instructions
okay well this is this is crap I haven't
are you beating me
I got a live one back a soccer ball I
don't know
hey you're beating this one how are you
doing Oh what was that pig with our
urinal beat meet me I have to come back
I must be the comeback kid
[Applause]
hello yeah I mean I'm actually just
throwing my arms the air and I don't
know what's happening
come on baby you must pay the price
oh I'm so hot guys actually surprisingly
I'm my workout what is what your mom you
do to put your on oh my goodness I need
a breather
well I still beat you - are we did let's
like one more but then I that's not
going to make you win it's not I simply
felt terrible I did it first I don't
know what the heck I'm doing I'm just
like flailing my arms around I'm taking
pictures I'm dancing over here oh whoa
bam bam boom the body is so warm oh
everything I know
I'll do the Whammer okay
[Music]
oh gosh I must through my remote and I
cook enough a cure
I keep like hitting the whole button I
keep the camera I'm dead again Todd yeah
not yet oh you got me Oh baby I'm sweat
my every listening isn't working as my
onyx women and I'm dying this is where
you have like all of the things that
produce heat yeah
well guys thanks so much for watching
well know what you may think of arms it
comes out on June 15th I'm gonna feel
this tomorrow yeah I know I
oh crap it really is there's a lot of
punching involved I feel like I need to
get the technique down of how to hold
the controllers because it's a very
weird feeling it's all about timing
oh no oh I can't rematch I'm so okay if
you want alright guys we'll see you
later bye champion I'm not
you